[Music]
hello my name is Andrew I'm one of The
Producers here at the long now
foundation so we all learned in
kindergarten that sharing is a virtue
one of those things that's essential for
playing together well yet as we get
older we're told to orient Our Lives
towards personal achievement Career
Development and accumulating property
often at the expense of sharing what
would it take to T program this
persuasive culture norm and take radical
sharing seriously what would it take for
you to willingly give up something you
love something that's part of your
identity or you worked hard for joining
us to explore these questions this
evening is beta adrion and Chelsea T
Hicks
[Applause]
beta is a Dutch artist and novelist who
came to us via our board member Brian
Eno and is the Visionary behind all the
programming for tonight Chelsea T Hicks
is an indigenous activist artist
musician and poet
enjoy welcome everyone um thank you so
much to the long now in the interf fall
for hosting us and thank you all for
being here and joining in this
discussion tonight we'll be talking
about property and
sharing more specifically we'll be
talking about the question what can
individuals and communities do in order
to change the trajectory of increasing
inequality in the long term I'll be
talking with Chelsea Hicks uh my guest
and fellow author who will join me in a
little bit and together we'll be looking
for answers and ideas and we also have
very exciting virtual guests who are
already taking action on this topic in
many ways as maybe a lot of you are
doing as well and they are going to
share their ideas and Thoughts with us
so before we get started I would like to
tell you a little bit about what got me
thinking about
inequality a few years back I started
writing my second novel called what's
mine and it's about a man named Louise
who lives in an apartment that he
inherited from his mother when someone
shows up who says Louise has inherited
this apartment in an unjust way from
there the story escalates and it
escalates in ways that I didn't imagine
when I started writing the book at the
same time my personal life was going
through very big changes as well when I
started writing the book I was in a
white privileged middle class kind of
way poor I was in a huge debt by the
time I was halfway through the book I
was no longer in debt I was no longer
poor and my life had changed massively
everything got a lot better when I got
out of crushing debt uh for instance I
was able to make my art I was able to
quit my cleaning job I was able to buy
materials for my art I sold a lot more I
got jobs that suited my skills better I
was able to go to important meetings in
London and Brussels and buy train
tickets I was even able to get a a
haircut for those meetings so while my
life improved massively I got stuck with
a novel
because I was writing about this guy who
had to ask himself am I really entitled
to what I have and how much can I share
and I wasn't ready to ask myself that
question I was so happy to get out of
trouble that that I didn't want to think
about that about sharing and all the
research I was doing for the book on
inequality on sharing on property rights
suddenly made me very feel really
uneasy well before these injustices just
seemed like something that someone else
should really be doing something about
and I
thought do I feel guilty about
inequality which seemed like such a
pointless feeling to me and then I
realized it was responsibility that I
felt and not in the sense that I felt
responsible but in the sense that I now
had room in my life to do something I
now had the ability to respond a
responsibility I found out there are a
lot of people who felt like me that they
had an unease about where Society was
and that they had this urge to take
action and the question
is what can we do I started uh together
with ANF and R theise who are both based
here in the Bay Area uh Network for
scientists artists people in media and
businesses to work together on social
topics the outcome so far has been
really incredible we've made a
children's book we've created a school
program that we implemented in schools
together with teachers and scientists
and we very often get together with
people from all kinds of fields to talk
about how can we effectively take action
so that's what we're doing here tonight
uh to see if we can find ways together
to take action 1% of the global
population holds 38% of global wealth
and I'm aware that you've heard these
percentages
before but I just want to repeat them
0.1% of the global population holds 11%
of global wealth while the poorest half
of the world holds 2% of global wealth
the people on the more pleasant side of
this equation are affected because when
inequality increases social cohesion
lessens and crime Rises so this is the
science I'm not a scientist I'm a story
oriented person I think about these
things through stories we can examine
our feelings true stories and we can
share our values through stories stories
and from our values we make
decisions and from our decisions we take
action my guest for tonight my co-host
is Chelsea T Hicks she's an Osage writer
and artist she's one of the first
authors to publish her book in her
ancestral language of
waji she has founded words of the people
and she's active in the land back
movement focusing on the concept of
rematriation which I'm sure she'll tell
us something about and I've gotten to
know Chelsea through her Story
collection a calm and normal heart in
which she introduces words from the Wazi
language welcome
Chelsea Val thank you beta it's so good
to be here and thank you everybody for
being here we're going to be talking
about a really big topic um we're going
to be talking about it by asking three
questions and the these questions will
be building on to each other so um the
first question is what is your own
connection to the words property and
sharing so how do you relate to those
Concepts what part do they play in your
life Chelsea what is your connection to
the words property and sharing yeah so
when I think about property and sharing
I think about uh home ownership first
and I live in my ancestral lands the
outer edge of waj or oage hunting
grounds which is in do deer tracks Tulsi
Tulsa Tulsa
Oklahoma and I want to own a home but I
don't and our reservation is nearby
about an hour north of Tulsa and I think
that owning a home there is a way to
signal to our community today that we're
invested in our people our language and
carrying on our ways however in
1906 uh that land which we had purchased
collectively from the Cherokees when we
were being forced out of Kansas that
land was allotted and that meant it was
divided up into individual plots of land
which we didn't know how to live that
way and it was it was very impactful in
a negative sense for our community and
we were also given oil head rights at
that time we had negotiated to own the
minerals six inches under the six feet
under the ground that had
um resulted in us becoming wealthy from
oil and then subsequently attracting
murders and violence against our people
so today oil is in mesh in our identity
and so I think I have and all Native
people today may have like a complex
relationship with ownership because we
can't live uh communally as we used to
you know it was outlawed and and we were
wared upon for for that concept so it it
holds a lot of
tension I read that the and correct me
if I'm wrong but the allotment Act was
forced on your people so they had to
before it was Community owned the land
they shared and then they were forced to
individually start owning it yes that's
right it was for
and you know today we still have aspects
of commun culture like our elanka dances
which Go the whole month of June we have
these Community dinners and anyone can
come and be fed but people who are
traditional Cooks could often throughout
the year be paid in blankets and they
may not have the money or the gas money
to get to the communal cooking uh in
order to feed all the people and you've
written this book and I really recommend
it's called a calm and normal heart and
in this book Chelsea introduces words
from the vashi language and through
these words that you learn as you read
the book you get to know concepts of
your culture did you learn about some
cultural concepts by um you started
learning the language right you didn't
grow up with it no did you learn uh some
cultural values as well as
you yes so you may hear their ter ter
rematriation tonight and it's another
way of saying it is reconnection Which
is popular for native people today
because in 1956 the Native American
relocation act took a lot of people away
from their reservations into cities my
paternal grandmother my EO had gone to
boarding school any native person today
has a grandparent who went to boarding
school like and the one of the results
of that is language loss and so no Osage
people today um speak Osage language
we're Rev izing it it's a dormant
language so those those Concepts that
are in the language one of them I can
note is you know in English we have like
this objectoriented sense a lot of
things are objects or function as
objects and subjects but in waj it's not
like that there's a lot more animacy
like and relationships to everything
especially uh plants and land so that's
another tie into ownership is there's
this idea of ancestral land and like
that our land is kind of uh living and
it's part of our
bodies so that's a concept from the
language that is that also why there was
a communal ownership of the land uh
instead of this individual chopping it
up into pieces I can imagine if you see
the Earth as a living thing you might
not be so inclined to chop it up
into or am I just fantasizing no as I
understand it you know more anciently
your bodies are sort of coming from an
ancestral land base when you look at
your four grandparents and where they
may have their ancestors may have lived
you know hundreds and hundreds of years
ago and and so when you're living where
there's a indigenous plants to that
continent and then you yourself are
indigenous to that continent there's a
kinship and a relationship as people in
the United States we don't necessarily
share these objectives or these ways
we're fragmented isolated and
disassociated from one another so
there's no basis for an inherent ability
to take care of and care for one another
because we don't necessarily share a
common
interest that's a really good answer and
I think it will link with uh our guests
tonight who are here on the screen first
is akit Tami she's a Tangi woman from
the kirima First Peoples of the Himalaya
she grew up in the tea plantations of
darjiling
and she moved uh she traveled to India
when she was 15 without any resources or
connections and she started working as
an artist since then she has founded the
sister Library which is the first
feminist Library of India she's also
started dafi art room uh dafi is known
as the biggest slum area in Mumbai and
in the middle Akia started an art room
where locals get together and make art
she has also started a fellowship for
girls to get a higher education
alongside this she somehow also has a
flourishing art practice Margaret Levy
she's a political scientist a professor
you may have seen her before here at the
interf fall and I got to know her
through her thinking and writing on the
concept of a community of Fate f a t e
not Faith Fai which is based on the
concept that we
all have a community of people that we
believe our faith is linked with Brian
Eno he is well known as a musician and
Artist as well as a writer and speaker
he is a co-founder of the long now he
founded a charity called Earth percent
in my own words it's a way to pay your
tax to the Earth so it allows for
artists to share a percentage of their
income with the Earth and this money
goes to groups that protect the planet
or help restore the planet and I've
asked them the question that I've asked
Chelsea I'm very involved right now in a
project that's actually thinking about
reimagining property rights it involves
an academic perspective which comes from
me and my team and two organizations uh
dark matter and radical exchange which
actually engaged in in on the ground
work of Designing new ways of property
rights and property writing as dark
matter calls it our goals here are to
transform the kind of mindset that we
have that was built at least in the West
in the 18th century and undermining in
many ways emphasizing private property
and therefore undermining all kinds of
common property and shared property
so our goal is to think about what
property can do for people and property
rights can do for people in terms of
economic well-being in terms of politics
and political equality and in terms of
protecting the environment the Earth and
indigenous cultures and then designing
institutions that will achieve those
ends and that are alternatives to the
current framework that we
have I think to approach the word
property I think of it uh from a very
decolonial standpoint because of my
identity as an indigenous person and how
my community the tangies did not really
have a concept of property as it is
experienced and uh is conceptualized in
the world today property in the sense of
owning land and owning a house and we
did not have that so we had like
communally owned spaces that were not
permanent it was always shifting and I'm
talking about like thousands of years
back when we lived as free people that
are not colonized there never was this
concept of really owning property really
owning land everything was there for
everyone to communally share and be a
part of and that is how I think of
property as well now like thank because
of this practice that my ancestors had I
think it's from memory in my jeans or
something I always longed for spaces
that are more
Collective spaces where we did not have
like a single authoritative figure who
would be the owner and the rule maker
and then everyone would have to adhere
to that and or generate wealth for the
owner of the property and maybe that is
why I never really had a job I became an
artist and uh started creating spaces
that could be owned by everyone where uh
people could think of ownership and
property differently and an example of
that could be sister Library where
people who come to the library I tell
them that the library is as much theirs
as it's my because the books have been
mine but it's an open space which is
community run everyone is welcome to
participate and think together to lead
the space in different
directions I think what's really needed
now is a discussion about what should be
in common
ownership what should be regarded as
Unown by any individual and what can be
allowed to be
private I think artworks being
relatively unimportant parts of the
world in some respects can be privatized
can can be
private I think Water
Supplies Land Air certain medical types
of um intervention shouldn't be private
I think they should be publicly earned
they should be a Commons in fact so of
course it's easy for somebody like me to
say they should be a Commons but the
question will immediately come so who
maintains the commons and who pays for
the commons this is a complicated
question and I don't know if this is the
place to try to answer that it's it's a
question I've been thinking about a lot
because certain aspects of my life that
are currently private I've tried to make
into a commments this studio for example
um more and more I use it as a place
where people meet to have conversations
so it's become a sort of it's become
common property of a lot of people
though of course my name is still on the
deeds and I still pay the rates but I've
tried to deal with this issue of uh what
should be privately
ownable and by saying that actually I'm
not sure that property of this kind
should be privately owned so I'm trying
to work out a kind of compromise which I
think
is a type of compromise that a lot of
people will have to be thinking about in
the future as the notion of unlimited
private property becomes more and more
difficult to sustain so you know there
are lots of people who own
things and perhaps like me they they
question whether they ought to own them
outright and maybe there is room for
some sort
of future where we make kind of Co Co
ownership agreements with the rest of
the world giving is is actually a bigger
pleasure than getting and I think one of
the social Transformations we might see
soon is the understanding of that that
to reverse that the sort of capitalist
model where pleasure comes from getting
and say no actually pleasure comes from
giving pleasure comes from
sharing
one thing that these uh speakers agree
on is that sharing seems increasingly
urgent and sharing of uh re rethinking
property rights seems necessary it
brings up this question of
responsibility with the second question
that we have how can we F fix best
injustices around property or improve
future ways of sharing and and you
shared a video with us has to do with
injustices and sharing I'll just play it
first it's by artist Nathan young do you
want to say something before we play it
so this video will be by Nathan Young
Who uh is lape and that's the land from
the from New York area in Manhattan and
he's a great tuls artist fellow and a
friend and he has this video with plain
Indian sign language which was a shared
way of talking sort of a common tongue
for native people who would come into
contact with each other so
yeah
in this video uh which is we were able
to get it from Oklahoma contemporary
show uh and so just acknowledging them I
think like we see this problem with
sharing and if you want to say okay
let's share right let's really go into
how can you do that how can you make it
work and sharing knowledge sharing
Resources with people with whom there's
a power imbalance or a values difference
uh clearly has has consequences and we
know that from the history of our nation
I think that with Native people today
you know native people have our own
stories and histories that we don't
necessarily share and not necessarily
willing to share knowledge or share
anything with people who we would deem
as as Outsiders or settlers or
non-natives and so in order to in
investigate how can you share I think
you have to look at at the value system
underlying the sharing and like what
kind of worldview and ethics and uh
Faith Community the the sharing is
coming from it's so you're what you're
touching on is this idea that you can
share but before you share if you
established you have to establish trust
so uh a mutual trust I guess yeah what
ways can trust be established you said
if you recognize that you have shared
values right because in Turtle Island
like on this continent when we're
encountering you know uh Church whites
right we're just seeing them as oh it's
a people who we don't know and they're
hungry and as Brian Eno is saying you
know sharing is the real gift like in in
oage culture you know generosity is one
of our important most important highest
values that when you show generosity
towards someone you're taking care of
them and that it creates a relationship
that you know they would take care of
you too and there's the a kinship of
just being a person and so that comes
from the idea that no people are are
really bad you know people aren't bad or
sinful but in in Christianity the
concept of forgiveness is very strong
and so you could be forgiven for a sin
if it was for God's will right but inia
we don't have a word for I'm sorry and
so if you there's there's more of an
emphasis on having good ways and doing
things that are respectful and so I
think we have to like acknowledge some
of the complications within like our
different worldviews and I think that
it's fine you know to have any religion
that you want but it's really important
to respect the radical dignity of every
person even if they don't believe the
same as
you I think another way that um we
establish trust it's not really trust
but that's by contracts by saying you'll
be punished if you don't do it right uh
the way we agreed upon so I guess that's
why we do it in business yeah um by
writing it down right contracts and law
as you as you address so well in your
book and yeah I mean I guess that's one
more thing I would note is that when it
comes to establishing the trust like why
native people would just automatically
help these people these Bey Poor Pitiful
these humble people that we don't know
is that when the Black robes or the
Jesuits came and they told us their
story of of Jesus we we had it in our
oral tradition that they gave us a stack
of leaves with a new moral code on it so
we were thankful for that because we had
now a new uh code which adds an
enrichment or a or a new just more more
abundance of understanding and we also
then told them our our stories because
it was understood that when someone
tells you their stories you believe them
and you respect it and it's holy and
it's sacred and there wasn't that
reciprocity within Christianity and the
way Christianity became tied to land
owning it was one one story is the only
one and and one way is the only one and
so I think if we can look at like the
foundational laws of our country and of
some of these contracts and where the
ideas come from that can help us like
recreate a sense of actually all people
are all nations are equal and all people
are equally dignified and it's not like
some people are basically Savages and
that those Concepts and those language
are still in our laws and they're still
alive and they still operate within our
minds even if we aren fully aware of
it oh let's watch what the the people on
the screen have said in reply to this
question on past injustices and future
ways of
sharing I have to say I haven't thought
very much about the first part of that
question past injustices and that's
partly because I suppose I see the
present
injustices so clearly as a continuation
of those anyway so I've been thinking
about how do we change things in the
present tense and of course one of the
most important of those is huge wealth
inequality which has increased
dramatically in the last 20 or 30 years
generally there's a Chasm opening
between the very rich and everybody else
so it's seems to me completely sensible
to have progressive
taxation aimed specifically at taming
that typ that
inequality and I also think having caps
on wealth is a very worthwhile idea
that's that's one that's the sort of
financial version of inequality the
other thing I think is important is to
try to see who we actually value in
society
and to perh perhaps ask ourself the
question of why is it that the people we
value most usually get paid
least so I think we have to fix past
injustices we see
particularly with land and buildings but
also other corporations as well I
shouldn't say particularly land and
buildings that there has been an in
Equitable from my perspective certainly
an unequal by all perspective
distribution of the income and even the
capacity to control what those buildings
provide and do or what those
corporations do so we have if we turn to
firms let's start there there have been
Arguments for a very long time about
polluting firms about what to do when a
firm that is say coal producing even
apart from the fossil fuel question but
when it's actually polluting the air
around it and who who pays to fix that
up or who pays for the health costs of
those who are both working in that plant
as well as those who are affected by
those that plant those are past
injustices which over time the laws have
evolved in part large part because of
public pressure often Union pressure
sometimes just
interest group lobbies and um mobilized
citizens to fix those clear injustices
that emerge from the property rights
when we look at big buildings today
particularly those which have
traditionally been offices in which a
lot of workers aren't returning to
there's lots of empty commercial office
space any big city almost anywhere in
the world right now is suffering and
some more than others is suffering from
a serious homelessness problem or a lack
of sufficient residents why can't we
transform some of those uh spaces into
residences well we can't because of the
nature of the property rights and who
has priority there in determining how
those things should be used and what
kind of income should be flowing from it
that's an injustice we need to change if
we are actually going to make some
distance on providing housing for all
those who need it given that we and not
building so much more housing and and
creating all kinds of environmental
problems with the drain on water and and
resources and land that we already have
in our Urban spaces and then the final
big Injustice of course is the Injustice
that comes from the way in which the
property rights system has worked
certain actors get a disproportionate
share of the revenue it's not surprising
right now that we're seeing unionization
begin to arise again at least in the
United States where it had clearly
declined so those are some of the kinds
of injustices that flow from property
rights and that can can be corrected by
action and By changes in
laws it's important to understand how
different societies also experience
property and how it is linked with part
power and uh relationship and social
hierarchy although it may not be true
for all the societies but like for some
societies like the cast Society in India
and in in other South Asian countries
there is relationship between property
ownership and cost status as well which
I think has to be dismantled in you know
as a child I never thought I was a
servant even if I grew up in a house
where everyone was in the plantation in
slavery I never thought I was destined
to be a slave because I did not
understand that and my parents never
told me that that is what I was destined
to be it was only when I left the house
I was told continuously that there's no
point even in my school I was told there
is no point studying because some people
are just meant to serve others there is
that very racist notion or like of
people who have been historically
disenfranchised to be just again like
just people who are supposed to be poor
and people who do not have that space at
all and for that like when we talk about
property and when we talk about sharing
I think these forms of injustices are
the ones that are still practiced and
practiced by people who are just like
everyday people you know people who
teach in universities to people who are
like working as Ria drivers it's like
across class who still hold these views
and it's because these are like these
are Notions that are pre modern forms of
governance it's like pre- democratic
system it is pre capitalism even it goes
beyond it goes beyond thousands of years
and so we'll have to start with radical
change there and for people to
understand that everybody is capable of
of experiencing ownership and property
and I think after we come to a space
where there is that understanding we can
start thinking of how property can be
experience differently and not just
through this very model of inheritance
and like this very patriarchal lineage
system it's interesting to me that well
Brian and Margaret are really practical
we need to get on with this and do these
things and they're very sensible areas
where our attention should be and then
there you and Aki emphasize before we do
this we need to establish trust see each
other acknowledge each other value each
other and restore some yeah
um problems MH yeah I think that the
first two had a an emphasis on systemic
and policy changes which can do so much
but in order to affect such a humongous
change as to create big more sharing and
and radical Equity I think it can't be
accomplish in one generation I think it
would take seven generations that's
usually the amount of time that native
people plan a cycle for and so I think
that it begins with the individual and
everybody that I really believe in
making reparations and reparative work
you can simply look at your ancestry
everybody has
like a lot of different ancestors and
some of your ancestors even from your
four grandparents you had the
grandparents that you liked and were
great and some of them you know needed
some support to act better in their life
and you can simply make reparations by
noting the communities that they may
have
disenfranchised and working to support
those communities I also think that you
shouldn't only be focusing on yourself
as this
like power holder and writer of past
wrongs you also need to look at your
disinheritance of what colonization and
Christian spread of Empire may have
removed from you anciently I think it's
um something simple that you can do is
look up a continent that you know you
have a deep protective spiritual tie to
hundreds and thousands of years ago and
look up a plant that grows indigenously
on that cont continent instead of
burning sage um in your apartment burn
that plant and pray with it and think
about your reparative work with it and
do your 10-minute calm meditation with
that plant instead of the you know the
commercialized smudging white Shamanism
thing you know I'm not saying you need
to go re indigenize yourself to a
continent and leave the United States
that's not what I'm saying I'm saying
that you can have more resources by
getting rid of some of that guilt by
doing reparative work looking at the
issues taking action praying with the
plants because that's a resource that
you deserve to have inherited that you
have been cut off from and it's a
horrible thing and you need to be rest
strengthened that you said that really
well I you said before the question of
what can individuals and communities do
you have spent some time thinking about
it and it was hard to answer and here
you go like this is what you can
do um let's look at what um Brian
Margaret and akie said about
it the answers in the question like
individuals and communities can do like
you know you have to start doing and
doing without expectation I think it is
something that I have also learned
through practice I was always taught to
expect a certain return after you do the
work but that's not how things work you
just do you just give you just share
without expecting there's going to be
this return so like when we are doing
the scholarship for the girls like the
working with savitri my fellowship or
like supporting the women in the harav
during the co crisis or uh just putting
together resources when there are floods
and or even doing the library I think
this idea that this is going to be the
input and this is going to be the output
of it is also sort of very
capitalist uh exchange and we I try to
step out of that and just do and it's
also this is the reason why we are not
funded by a huge corporation or any
Grant because this is what the grants
ask as well like you know you put this
and then there has to be a result and
then there has to be a multiplication of
that result and you have to scale up
that's not how I function at all you
just do and then it may turn into
something that is positive and it may
turn into something that is great but it
may not also but that should not stop us
from doing and I think everybody is
capable of doing like everybody is
capable of giving back here I'm going to
come right back to politics I really
think political Solutions are needed and
that involves ensuring political
equality one so getting making sure that
everybody who wants to vote can vote
that they're as informed as they can
possibly be that they have the political
capacity to exercise voice in
appropriate ways but it's incredibly
important to build
democracies that one not only listen to
those various voices and take them on
and help to resolve conflicts in the
ways that we've been talking about but
also by creating that kind of democracy
and reduc and creating political
equality within democracy we reduce the
power of the
superpowerful and increase the power of
the less powerful and of the ma of the
majority really of the multiple voices
that need to be heard and that I think
is crucial for achieving economic
equality because what's standing in our
way here what's standing in our way is a
series of government rules that in we're
back to property rights here that enable
certain people to disproportionately
benefit from the kinds of property
rights structure that we have and if
we're going to change the rules of the
game if we're going to change the
legislation that requires immense
political pressure and it has to be a
relatively even playing field and it is
not right now so what do I think people
should do they need to vote but they
need to mobilize others to vote they
need to fight they need to fight for the
issues they care about in a way that is
civil and takes into account the
interests of others and they have to be
able to to exert political pressure in a
collective way on their legislate
legislators so that some change can
actually be brought
about the
first uh realization we have to have is
that there are no
externalities if you are producing
things and using resources and and
dumping uh the waste from those you have
to take responsibility for for every
effect of of what you're doing in as far
as those things can be measured and
discerned that actually straight away is
a huge inequality reducer the second
thing I'd say is as Margaret Levy said
unionization that is so important I
think it really makes a difference if
workers have a voice and their voice is
recognized and
respected third thing I'd talk about is
reform of politics
itself we're stuck with political models
that really date from the 19th
century and yet there are new ones
emerging which are much much more
interesting and exciting and liberating
and those are things like citizens
assemblies particularly the kinds of
citizens assemblies that have
participants chosen by
Lottery um or sortition as it's known
the last thing I would say we could do
and this might seem like a quite weirdly
uh
authoritarian stance to take is that I
think social media have to be reformed
quite radically at the moment we're
living with social media whose
algorithms are specifically designed to
create
polarization
discontent argument and
distraction and we more than ever we
need citizens to be
engaged at the level of policy decision
decisions this is why that first
suggestion of um citizens assemblies is
important but we need them to be
informed there's no point having
citizens engaged in things if they're
completely befuddled by the kind of
rubbish that Fox News is putting out so
we really need to start
thinking
knowledge understanding of the situation
that we're in at present is at a
absolute
premium so those were a lot of potential
areas where we could take action was
there one thing that was mentioned that
is significant to you stands out where
you think
decolonizing um how we interact with our
environment just through protecting land
to give an example in Tulsa right now
they're looking at building a third Dam
near the South part of Tulsa and part of
the reason that uh people can't kind of
take action against the dam is because
there's a narrative like a teaching and
an understanding of of a river and this
idea of what a river should look like it
should have a European aesthetic because
it's still in some ways a colony here in
the US and the Arkansas River is
actually a braided Prairie stream it's
not supposed to look like a high water
river it's supposed to look like
sandbanks with streams of water weaving
through and so when people look at the
river and they say h how ugly wouldn't
it be nice if it looked beautiful like a
river so why not build another Dam
because it fits into like my aesthetic
that I'm bringing as like a colonial
inheritance and so if you can just
that's an example like just by
protecting if you can stand up for the
dam you build the sense of community you
can protect the land and just the the
push back against that kind of 1% thing
that you achieve through that results
and people feeling more like there's a
sense of community I should show up to
vote because people are working to
protect each other so I don't know if I
outlined that really well but I think
that when you go into one area of this
you go into all the areas of it and it
has this ripple effect between land
people wealth
property and and it also dies in with
what both Margaret and Brian pointed out
uh the importance of being informed and
getting your inform
yeah if you think that River you want
the river to look nicer you know but if
you're informed you can make a better
judgment and so these are all huge
things that have been suggested um we've
been asking what kind of things can we
do what kind of projects can we embark
on um some things are uh individual so
can we make a personal commitment start
can we start looking at our ancestors
where we came from what the that means
can we make a commitment to take
responsibility or try to make a
commitment if we have room in our lives
to be responsible for all the
externalities that are uh that are
caused by our existence uh could it be
communal should be local or Global
should be an art project a storytelling
project or should it be political like
Margaret is saying who should the target
audience be of a project like this uh
could it be children or politicians
there's a lot of uh questions and I
think what is sure is that we need to do
things um and we need to get out of
paralysis if we're in paralysis and what
will motivate us to do
things uh I think it's our
feelings I think the things we talked
about today um how we feel about each
other who we trust uh the feelings that
we have about sharing in that might be
changing the feelings about who do we
value in society um a big motivator for
people is how can I be happier you said
you became happier when you connected to
your ancestral landens and your value
so this is where you come in at a really
hard part um we would really like your
personal take on this you all have this
piece of paper with a question what can
individuals and communities do in order
to change the trajectory of increasing
inequality in the long term now we will
have some time for you to write down
whatever you want to write down and to
ask uh questions with such an ingrained
cultural historic
architectural and Community set of
biases that we have inherited that have
led us to the position where we have
given over so much control of our plan
planet to so few
people what fundamental change needs to
happen in our thinking that has allowed
us to give it all away so that we can
find a way to take it
back you talked about values talked
about feelings what is that thing that
has allowed us as a civilization as a
people as a society to give
99.9% to .1% I think it's the concept
yeah thank you for the for the
insightful question I think it's the
concept that land is an object and that
our bodies are not land our bodies are
land we walk on the land we are animals
with the other animals we're part of we
are the land and the land is a person
the land is
animate my take on this is it's tied to
what I found out uh as I got out of debt
uh if you're in debt there's nothing you
can do like you're in just constantly
stressed um you can't expect much from
people who are in that situation once
you get more room to think and to feel
and you're able to do things you realize
how much of your um humanity is actually
stolen by the systems that we're living
in if I walk past that person who is
passed out I don't want to uh but I
cannot get involved I've done it in my
life and it doesn't turn out well
because I don't have the skills to fix
problems that huge but that is taking
something from me uh it's it allows it
it doesn't allow me to be the person who
I want to be and I think when we start
recognizing that the fact that we have
no choice to buy but buying tomatoes
that were harvested by people who are
underpaid that we have no choice to join
a bank uh but to join a bank who is
involved in land grabbing in Africa that
is changing who we are it's changing our
personality we have to mute parts of
ourselves if you want to expand the
concept Beyond like that that's what I
think the change that needs to happen is
but as to how you get toward that and
how you integrate that understanding
into every aspect of life the like
curriculum set for it is
rematriation and everyone can
participate in rematriation it's
indigenous and black women L I believe
some people think it's just indigenous
women LED but I think that black and
Indigenous people need to work together
to help lead reparative work in the
United States but I think that you're
just first of all it's kind of a simple
process but it it goes beyond
self-care because
self-care you can still get in trouble
and get attacked for appropriation and
someone's going to tell you go get your
own culture and so that's where
rematriation came in was it's a form of
self-care
that is anti- appropriative and
anti-racist foundationally and by Nature
so rematriation means reparative work
for your ancestors as well as learning
what you've been disinherited of
reconnecting to the things that you've
lost you can do that through land and I
focus on land like to give you like a a
broader brief overview of people who
speak about these ideas and examples you
have N Scott Maday Robin wall kimmerer
and Natalie Diaz and they each have a
different kind of recommendation for you
of how you do this Robin wal Kimmer will
her rhetoric is as I understand it's
kind of you can indigenize yourself to
the land where you live now by learning
the beliefs of tribes by whom you live
and uh kind of allying with them if you
can ever get them to even speak to you
I added that last part I noticed and
then N Scott Mamay is saying kind of
like okay I want to acknowledge that
Cowboys and Ranchers have also lived on
the land and they know the land and
everyone has achieved some type of
belonging in the United States through
their tenure here and so go beyond your
tenure and begin to uh keep the Earth
and he he talks about that through a
story of like the Grasshopper And that's
in the book Earth keeper so it's kind of
I think I would translate it as to like
basically if you spend time with land
this is an idea that Dr Phil Cash Cash
uh who nimi poo uh will say in the land
will will speak to you it will you'll
get you'll get ideas through
meditatively sitting with land and put
it that way in like the sort of English
thought World thought worldview and then
Natalie Diaz will have none of either of
those things and she says no you need to
go back back to your ancestral Waters
and immerse your body in them because
there's certain things you can't
understand when you are disconnected
from Land you come from Land you come
from people and we when we come we
become so disconnected from that we
can't understand how to really be
healthy and you know I think
Christianity and other it becomes Like A
coping mechanism that's you know maybe
better than like alcoholism but I don't
know that it's able to reverse the it
doesn't have
necessarily in and of itself
solely the tools to reverse where we are
in terms of our our species taking care
of each other and being able to continue
surviving we at time for the evening
give it up for Beth and
Chelsea
[Music]
yeah